denys tremblay je suis militante et
directrice de la séjournelle
[Musique]
porter plainte contre son conjoint love
est assez difficile on pouvait pas
parler non plus de viol à l'intérieur du
couple
la première mission de ces journées
c'est d'assurer la sécurité des femmes
et des enfants
pense pas au québec que ça peut exister
qu on se promène sur la rue et qu'on a
peur de se faire tuer un lit de l'espace
de rangement et les femmes peuvent aussi
apporter des objets personnels la
séjournelle reçoit en hébergement à
chaque année peu près 75 femmes 75
enfants et je dirais une centaine de
femmes qui viennent en externe c'est à
dire qu'ils viennent pas en hébergement
mais qui viennent nous consulter
on va accompagner les femmes dans tout
ce qui est une démarche légale donc allé
rencontrer l'avocat
allez vérifier si on était qu
admissibles à l'aide juridique
d'accompagnement au tribunal s'il ya une
plainte
si je décide de me séparer les gardes
d'enfants des rencontres avec la dpj le
médecin la recherche d'un logement
après midi dayal ya une femme qui est
accompagné d'une intervenante et les
policiers sont là pour aller récupérer
des effets personnels fait que c'est le
genre de choses qu'on fait
il n'ya pas non plus de limite dans le
nombre de fois qu'elle peut venir et
c'est gratuit
il ya au québec plus d'une centaine de
ressources comme la nôtre
imaginez que ce réseau n'existe plus
qu'est-ce qui se passerait les femmes
seraient où il ya des femmes qui ont des
diplômes universitaires ya des femmes
qui sont chefs d'entreprises des femmes
qui sont à la maison et que
contrairement à ce qu'on pense le seuil
c'est la violence conjugale arrive dans
tous les milieux nucléaires pour lui
peut-être vie on voyait facilement quand
j'ai commencé dès 30 ans d'union la cedh
une deux trois quatre
avec ça c'est encourageant ça veut dire
que socialement on commence à dire on
peut faire quelque chose d'inacceptable
il ya des ressources te prend du temps
sorti en deux ans par oui on sent une
maison d'hébergement c'est pas l'heure
pour faire séparer les femmes et briser
les familles si monsieur prend massive
en thérapie ici fait des démarches puis
sincère pas tant mieux ça vaut de la
voir faire et à gérer ce couple un loupé
de rue et les angevins paraît derosier
je trouve ces les femmes qui sont les
plus courageuses c'est elles qui font
vraiment la différence nous on est là en
appui pour ce qu'elles veulent va
mon rêve le plus fou que la maison ferme
complètement je pense que je peux pas
comment ce rêve là c'est irréaliste par
quand je peux rêver que les femmes et
les hommes vont travailler de plus en
plus de soldats puis ça je pense qu'avec
la prévention avec l'éducation
on peut y arriver moi j'aurais fait mon
petit bout de chemin
puis les autres continuent
[Musique]